and that means no sci-fi book isn't that
right Rick haha how the did they get
Rick to come along on this trip I feel
like if four seasons of Rick and Morty
taught me anything it's that Rick will
be willing to turn himself into a pickle
if necessary to get out of stuff like
this Thank You Morty for telling us all
what a Faraday box is I mean I know what
it is but you know not everyone did but
also Morty has seen Rick build all sorts
of crazy things how did he instantly
know that Rick was building a Faraday
box and not let's say a deadly
jack-in-the-box or a box to hold a bomb
or glory knows what else why go through
all the trouble of building a Faraday
box if throwing the phone out the window
was an option and no I'm not saying
Faraday box over and over so I remember
it I super already knew that it was
called a Faraday box you know what's
really bugging me about this scene the
steering wheel seems to be very low
while yes this gives us a great view of
the car it would be chafing Jerry's legs
the entire Drive I love this contraption
Rick is stalled into the station wagon
but is he attached to the door the back
seat doesn't come with him so what's
holding Rick up during this transition I
hope you realized the tubing permit was
non-refundable relax Jerry we'll be in
and out in a minute
all this talk of lube and being in and
out in a minute reminds me of a what Oh
tubing right oh man they got to Rick's
baby mama fast I was hoping they were
going to do a twisted take on the movie
lock stop encouraging people to stick
their divining rods into earth holes
doesn't anyone remember the 1999 penis
burn epidemic after American Pie and
there are critters in those planet holes
come on the problem here is a perfectly
missed opportunity to show the animators
ability to draw anything other than it
can balls we've seen after a after hairy
ball and when it comes time to show the
beauty that is the vulva we get a
[ __ ] multi-tiered crater with a
sphincter in the middle they really
really don't I mean just because they
have pointy hair doesn't make them look
like Rick the father could be Lisa
Simpson for all they know a little steam
and then Rick summons a thing from the
station wagon and that's all it takes
apparently for Rick to build an entire
factory out of this planet's womb why go
back there when you have the most
interesting mystery developing right in
front of you Jerry creates this murder
stick for no reason oh you think it's
for roasting marshmallows but nope he
whips a metal stabby tool out for that
why is this stick being whittled because
if you move the bar so low you might
actually seem like you're worth it
geez they turn Jerry into this shows Meg
Griffin didn't they they can heap all
sorts of abuse on him without him
fighting back and is it funny you just
end up feeling sorry for the guy is dumb
and listless as he is I mean this kind
of lashing out would be reserved for a
jury who actually did summers friend
from the primordius episode shouting in
helpful directions at the woman giving
birth with directions that are in fact
simply stating what she was already
doing heinous fruit also freaking Beth
were going through all the trouble of
helping these clay Rick's achieve
fulfillment why confuse them from the
start with what the number two really is
is it a watermelon a pear why can't it
just be a number also we have a pie
chart with an actual pie on it and we
have another screen that shows how you
definitely don't play tic-tac-toe sure
just give the O's the game X's it's not
like anybody bet all their life savings
on yet another draw why is the sign for
in turns plural when everything else is
singular this might be the worst sin
Rick and Morty has ever committed just
push them out through a pipe in the back
I knew it wouldn't be long before I had
to remove a sin yes you don't want to
learn how to skip rocks either the first
step in skipping a rock is to choose a
rock that will skip and not immediately
sink to the bottom of the water the
second step is to choose a body of water
that is still in laxa current in yeah
maybe this is the joke but if Jerry skip
stones by selecting tiny boulders to
chuck at rivers he wouldn't be
interested in teaching his kids because
you would constantly fail with this task
also Jerry survives this this series of
blocks contain zero kubert's
okay where did Jerry get us more he
cooked one earlier and gave it to summer
who threw the once more into the fires
of Mount dysfunction a couple minutes
ago does Jerry just have spare s'mores
in his bag I grant that this is
something that Jerry would do but I'm
sending it anyway also now that we've
sinned that Jerry even should have one
in the first place let's discuss the
fact that Jerry is the sort of person
who keeps an unprotected s'more in
his bag he is also the sort of person
who can pack the fragile s'more in such
a way that it doesn't crumble even
though he survived a river factory and
fall so really I don't know if I should
respect him fear him or hate him what is
that this this is camping that is a can
store well I guess that seals it I hate
Gerry encouraging incest also I guess
it's a standards and practices thing but
if these two really are pumping cheeks
then the lack of motion means they're
doing it wrong so your boobs in vagina
are okay then by the way it would be
awesome if summer was ribbing more to
here for actually eating human flesh in
the last episode if summer is going to
be the teenage girl version of Rick this
would have been a perfect opportunity
for that callback but it doesn't even
seem this episode knows what happened in
the last episode well everyone on earth
at this point should be familiar with
the events of get schwifty in which you
had to show an alien what you got and
what you got ain't that you guys self
reference a lot when it comes to your
writing anxieties but characters not
remembering things like that is crazy to
me sorry sorry just trying to get the
hang of this thing
who is he apologizing to his family that
would be dead right now had the staff
worked as he thought it did oh sorry I
didn't kill you in a glorious fashion
just the noob c-can Jerry
we'll just try to smite me Siri triangle
power did you for real just use Siri to
triangulate this God source of power
geez our communications companies are
going to know everything you see my true
feeling too guy is mine wait so why do
all of your kids look like the illusion
of you does anyone know who kid rocky is
anymore
mixing Zeus with Sofia Hadoop on telly
would make more sense and probably be a
more interesting Google search honestly
also looks like somebody got some
Deadpool in my Rick and Morty let's go
this goes on for some time also the
power of a god versus a guy who has
gadgets in knowledge of a god and we're
about to see a fist fight wait a DC
Comics show this ship has power also not
only does it have power they're able to
get the ship off the ground from this
position and with a bunch of roots and
vines running through it I think it's
the thrusters but no matter whether it's
wings or thrusters this ship somehow
gets into space we never once get to see
one of Jerry's plagues even if they're
as lame as best says they are I want to
see the full brunt of Jerry's plagues
machina X Day use show thinks that Jerry
can use his marshmallow roaster thing to
pull Beth out of the chasm and if four
seasons of this show has taught me
anything about Jerry show is
contradicting itself about Jerry this is
another one of those weird animation
things the lava was so close to them
here that I don't know how they didn't
get melted by the lava before they climb
aboard the ship it's one of those things
where they're saved because the show
says they are then I refuse to accept
that do you put the fire stick to the
wood the whole time one of nah tricks
kids would be amazing at TV sins oh yeah
about that title children of Mort it's a
children of men parody title I get that
and I get the children part I just don't
get the Mort part unless it's some
clever nods all the death in the episode
but you know how much I hate
acknowledging the French remember when
they were episode titles that didn't
need to fit the Rick or Morty in like
lawnmower dog they didn't call that lawn
Morty dog well I love this bit at the
end where Rick is scrolling through a
planet dating site I'm wondering what
planet would call themselves - are - f18
one like they're content with the
name some earth scientists gave them
[Music]
erogenous ozone
I've created Lutheran's well I killed
all the old merchants a ritualistic
bonfire them from the ashes Rose a new
merch enterprise ha ha ha grab a cloaca
cast a stone or do the cliche fan thing
and Scipio me out of a sexy mug and a
code ding for a discount because you
were amazing fans and we appreciate you
now stop and go get your sweet new swag
link below or find our store at cinemas
INSCOM you want me to read I'm reading
text what's the difference first you
take the ground you stick the chocolate
on the ground then you roast the malla
when the mall is flaming you stick it on
the chocolate then you cover it with the
other end then house I come to bar near
Elsa your other hand honey I can't hold
too